you are a world-renowned chef all right
hey mr. out the world yeah let's let's
admit like the chuck wepner of chefs
okay do you ever eat fast food I would
think that would be difficult because
you're very famous everyone knows you
and you're always talking about the
purity of the food and it's gonna be a
real experience can you go and get fast
food and not well I I talk smack about
the you know the King the clown and the
colonel all hot and so it's tough for me
when in the middle of the night I
suddenly get like us you know maybe I'm
in a bad decision-making period of the
evening let's put it that way
perhaps you know I've been in an altered
state of consciousness and suddenly
hungry and and often I fight for that
get a fast-food macaroni and cheese it's
not even the chicken it's a kernel it's
that that that orange bright are and I'm
not even sure it's cheese it's some sort
of weird glowing orange color yeah I'll
put a hoodie on and I'll slide into the
into the kernel hoping that no one will
get a big tub of that stuff and I'm
always like a just half way out the door
and so Anthony Bourdain yo dude and
they'll take the picture and you know
you know what the feelings like if you
ever like walked out of like you didn't
even caught by a neighbor coming out of
like a strip mall porn shop with like
anal rampage under your arm yes I think
we've all had that experience it's so
awkward yeah yeah that's the problem is
I'm often caught returning it
there are this one doesn't work yeah I
don't like the de Lorean you are not a
fan of Johnny Rockets that's a popular
hamburger place out here in Los Angeles
and I think I think it's around in parts
of the country Johnny Rockets are you
really don't like Johnny Rockets what
happened look I've eaten a lot of really
nasty stuff a show but nothing is
soul-destroying is my Airport Johnny
Rockets experience I went into it like
there were like two managers a cashier
three cooks there's no one else in the
airport I'm alone there I'm hungry you
know I order a burger they throw a cold
burger on a pathway on a bun reach in
and the fry basket for a simply cook
fries they don't need to dunk it in the
grease flow a limp pickle on a slide you
know they were all standing there in a
row nothing else going on no other
customers
they sort of slid it across at me all
looking at me and we all sort of stood
there silently for a second kind of
sharing this moment of perfect misery
where we wanted to be and I had such
things rightly or wrongly send me into a
spiral of misery and depression that
lasted three days so it was really the
most all-destroying
recent meal experience not a fam now
okay at the end so I say no all right so
if there was a Johnny Rockets in
Switzerland what would it take to get
you there
Wow I can't even think of anything that
I would you know I don't think I could
overcome there's so much hammer it out
yodeling man giving you a Johnny Rockets
murder
you